foreign
home of the wire and talk to the great
Melissa what's up Melissa
hey Dr John how are you I'm great how
are you
good it's an honor to get to talk to you
today well thank you for calling how can
I help
um so I guess I'm gonna cannonball in
um start off saying something
that I've never said out loud and I
guess I'll say it out loud to all 18
listeners okay I want to stop you before
you do it okay this is kind of my rule
of thumb when anybody says I've never
said this before
yeah always want to stop them
and make sure I'm the right guy
okay am I the right guy
I think so okay I think so if you're
doing anything illegal I still have to
hold you accountable for that is that
cool
that's cool nothing illegal okay all
right
if you if you're if you're totally
comfortable for everybody listening
anytime somebody says I've never told
anybody this but I need to tell you
something
stop because if they tell you something
you might have to act on it okay so
Melissa I'm trusting you and I promise
I'll sit with you go for it
um I have been abusing pain medication
for over four years now prescription
pain medication
I had a previous problem with it in my
20s I ended up going to treatment I was
clean for five years and then about 10
years ago I was in a car accident and
injured my spine pretty bad ended up
having to have spinal surgery
um and have been in pain management for
about
yeah four or four years now
um my husband and my family don't know
that I'm taking opioid pain medication
I've never told them I think because of
the
stigma of what happened you know when I
was in my 20s when I didn't have
legitimate pain that I live with chronic
pain every day of my life now
um and
I just
I I'm ashamed
um in a way but at the same time I feel
Justified a little bit
but I'm constantly beating myself up
over it because
I am constantly running out of my pain
medication early and everything is great
until that point you know I have energy
I do well at work I participate in my
life you know I can concentrate on
things but then as soon as that
prescription runs out everything comes
crashing down and it's like I just crawl
into a black hole for you know as long
as it is until the next time you know I
am able to to get my prescription
refilled
um okay can I can tell you a few things
that are hard yeah
well first of all thank you for saying
that out loud I'm really proud of you
I would hug you if you were sitting here
and I probably wouldn't say anything for
the next five or ten minutes I just sit
here with you
thank you
how did that feel saying that out loud
um
out of body kind of experience
you'll probably feel some instant relief
and then the shame Waters will slowly
start circulating back through and a
little bit to fill up that space
I want you to know I'm proud of you okay
for just for saying that out loud
here's some hard truths that you know
um but it's just gotten a little bit
hazy
your family knows
they may not know exactly what
but they know
and that idea that you can focus and
everything is better and I become more
of a laser
that's the addiction talking again
yeah
because it's not right because I promise
you your colleagues are like man what is
up I promise you
and so there's this moment what what
made you say I've got I've got to get
I've got to say this out loud I've gotta
I've got to do something different
something happened
nothing happened I just feel like I've
been doing this dance for a while where
you know I find the gift of desperation
to stop and then
I just don't have you know the willpower
and then I think of like the fact that
I do have legitimate chronic pain but I
need help with holding myself
accountable because obviously I'm not
doing it well and you can have chronic
pain that's managed in different ways
than just yeah throwing opiates at it
right
um all right so let's walk through this
together
you call a meeting tonight with your
husband and you take him out and you say
I have to have a hard conversation with
you
and you say I've been using for four
years and we both know that I've got
these prescriptions but
um
I'm burning through the prescriptions
I'm even getting some other ones from
another doctor from friends
um
I've reached a point where I can't
control this
what happens then that next
um
I fear that he would never look at me
the same way again
because
I think
it's not so much the using but
the line
and the hiding things and the deterrent
like the Betrayal
that I think would really hit him harder
than anything else
and
I'm just terrified that
if I have that conversation if I
yeah that he would never look at me the
same way again and that it might end up
ruining our marriage
what's the chances he reaches over gets
up from where he is and comes and hugs
you and holds you so tight you can
hardly breathe
um
I honestly don't see that happening okay
okay what if you told him I'm gonna tell
you something and when it's over
it's going to be hard for you
but I need you to get up and come over
and sit by me and just hug me and not
say anything for a minute
and if you told him I'm embarrassed
about the lies I'm embarrassed about the
shame but I'm sick
and we've been through this before and I
gotta go through it again
I think it's probably writing all that
stuff down and reading that out in some
shape form or fashion
but one of the most common things I hear
on the front end of somebody coming
clean is
I'm afraid everybody's going to do x y
and z
and it just doesn't always happen that
way sometimes yeah people react poorly
or they they make it about them and all
that
yeah but sometimes I don't
know and let me tell you this
you know me on if you listen to this
show I'm always dude I want to go to the
ends of the Earth to try to save
marriages because I think marriage is a
beautiful thing
but I'd rather your marriage
I'd rather you'll go separate ways than
you die and you know how this ends
and you got little ones too right
I don't actually no kids okay good yeah
no kids and not planning on kids okay
just pause
when you use before
the the the pain
what were you cut what were you duct
taping over
anxiety
social anxiety
um
just feeling
I don't know a lack of self-confidence
you know there wasn't anything there
wasn't any major event any trigger I
didn't have you know any trauma in my
childhood I
I mean legitimately had a very good
childhood and I have two loving parents
who you know would do absolutely
anything for me
um and I think it just
my marriage
um
all right let me say something really
harsh okay yeah
I question how strong
the bot buying the bounding The Binding
is in your marriage
if you think you come to him in a moment
of illness and he bails
either that's the addiction talking or
your marriage is is not a secure Bond
it's not a secure attachment
I think it's more of the addiction
talking because
I mean
when I'm not having this kind of
conversation and I just kind of think
think about it I mean he
he's always told me you know that he's
in for the Long Haul he's not he's never
going to leave me you know he
believes in just marriage as an
institution and
I just like I don't
I don't think that he would actually
leave I think what I'm more afraid of is
like I said him just never looking at me
the same way again
and just
going through the motions and me not
being able to so don't dress rehearse
tragedy your dress rehearsing tragedy
don't invent problems that haven't
happened yet and try to solve them in
the present
yeah
give him an opportunity to step up
and give him a road map to what that
looks like
[Music]
here's the truth you've been through
this before
getting off this is brutal
yeah
going to AAA again what you gotta do is
brutal
yeah
going through this process will be very
difficult and you're worth every second
of it
Have you listened to uh if you haven't
already I would love for you to go
listen to
armchair expert with Dax Shepard and his
co-host Monica and the episode is called
day seven
okay and his claim to fame was 15 years
sobriety
and he was a mentor for countless people
he was a sponsor for countless people
then he had an accident
and he had to reckon with starting over
because he used again and started hiding
him
and it's one of the most beautiful
heartbreaking hard
but truly extraordinary pictures of what
this actually looks like
yeah it sounds too familiar I want you
to I want you to listen to the episode
because his friend Monica holds him
accountable
and
she says I love you in the same in the
same conversation
and there's ownership and there's
accountability and there's heartbreak
and there's shame and there's
forgiveness in the whole thing it's a
beautiful picture of it in real time but
it really applies here
but I want you to remember two important
things number one Secrets will kill you
yeah
right
yeah and so you got to have this
conversation sooner rather than later
the second thing is
you're worth being well and you're worth
being sober
will you commit to having this
conversation with him
yeah I will
I have to I know I have to I'm really
proud of you
thank you
so I want you to listen to that episode
day seven we'll see if we can find it
and link it in the show notes it's been
a year or two
um since it came out
um
and feel free to give me a call feel
free to have him give me a call on the
back end after you have this
conversation okay you can both call into
the show talk to you both at the same
time
um I want you when you sit down with him
to already have a plan like I'm going to
a meeting in the morning
I don't want it to just be an open-ended
thing where he's kind of off untethered
all of a sudden and also like I said
give him a path back tell him I I know
I'm so full of Shame right now I can
hardly keep my eyes open
I just need to know that you love me and
will you hug me
yeah
and
tomorrow when we wake up I would love it
if you made breakfast and I'd love it if
you drove me down to my meeting or I'd
love it if we had coffee together and we
didn't talk about it and then I'm gonna
go to the meeting and you ask me about
how the meeting went
I'm actually going to a meeting tonight
good for you
so maybe after the meeting you tell them
and maybe after you get a sponsor
tonight you guys get somebody's number
tonight you got somebody you can call
after the meeting because it means it
might be hard it might go awful
yeah but it has to happen right
it does because yeah I I know like you
said I know how this ends yeah
I've seen it happen to too many of my
friends
over the years that's right
but on the other side of it I've got
some friends who are sober and their
families are incredible and they laugh a
lot and they're silly and funny and they
have good marriages and they've got good
jobs
so there's light on the other side too
and make no mistake I'm not going to
sugarcoat it opioids are a demon man
they will hang on your soul they're
tough they're tough tough tough tough
there's biochemical reasons for it
they're tough
gotta have a group of people go with you
but you're worth being well my sister
I'm so so proud of you call anytime have
your husband call anytime y'all call
together
I'll walk with you as long as you'll
have me
but let me know how this conversation
goes let me know how tonight's meeting
goes I'm so proud of you
good